so I got to tell you guys what happened
so
we went to the Tennessee football game
and it's an orange team
it's really there's no they're not even
playing about it I never I hadn't seen
this much Orange
um
I'd never seen it I mean this is where
Zach Bryan would play probably his you
know he could just shoot a video there
but anyway so we uh we go to the game
right we go to the game and
what's that guy not Jerry Goff
who played quarterback over there really
great guy he's played probably five
years ago I think his name is not Bobby
yeah Josh Dobbs sorry
same amount of letters as Jerry golf I
got invited by him
and his fella Allen so anyway I'm at the
game
uh Caleb Presley's at the game and
we go down to the field before the game
I never been this close to a game in my
life I mean we're on the few we're like
right there there's like somebody like
shook my hand or whatever or hugged me
or something I don't know it could have
been a handshake and the guy's hand was
so big that it was ended up being a hug
I mean they just had some grippers out
there
so anyway I um because we're close to
the field like
and you always kind of think you're like
oh I could like the second I got this
close to the field I realized I could
never play any sport ever
so that is it's one of the side effects
of going that close to the field
so then like everybody leaves and the
game starts
well we're upstairs just having a couple
Franks or whatever and just you know
just living life a couple D Peppers baby
just mustarding up some Frank's dog and
uh just you know cheering yelling stuff
Whispering stuff to chicks just whatever
dude being alive it was like
it seemed like a lot of everybody's
orange everybody's orange tan orange
eyeballs people jaundice you don't know
what's going on a lot of liver ailments
I don't know what the hell is going on
but everybody is just orange as could be
we're enjoying it man it's a blast
people are just you know treating us
well and we're meeting former players
and having a great time and then at some
point we go back down to the field like
at the end of the third quarter and so
we're standing by the field and
like secure like P like SEC we just kept
getting like kicked
you like kicked out but like kicked
closer to the team
like the guy was like if you're with the
team you need to get with the team
and I've always wanted to be with with a
team you know I've always wanted to play
ball or you know take a shot at it so
we'll just keep being by the team you
know and then
like after getting kicked
I guess kicked into the game only we got
people just kept coming up get closer to
the team like it was like
like we couldn't even see our friends
anymore like it was so we're just then
like we're just on the bench
I mean we're on the bench dude there's
people I taped up some guy's hands I'm
not even joking I taped up some guy's
hands the Snapper the um
I don't know what it was a snack or the
red snap or whatever I don't know what
the guy's called dude there was a point
where I think we honestly almost could
have gotten the game
I think if I hadn't been standing there
vape and I think somebody would have put
me in
but anyway uh
we're over there we're chest bumping
people people are sweating on us dude
we're licking it off of them we're
[ __ ] in the game bro you know what
I'm saying and uh and then the clock
starts ticking down and we're like man
this is amazing like people are
celebrating
um it's just been such a you know we're
just there like we know seven or 18
players now uh so then it gets close to
the end of the game and we're like man
we gotta celebrate dude how do we do it
this is our team
and uh and we're like we asked people
hey is anybody gonna water the coach up
you know do Gatorade and everybody's
like nah nah man I wouldn't do that that
ain't look we don't you shouldn't do
that and that's I'm like I know some of
these guys are younger than me they
don't know the value of that they don't
know that it means we did it
so
the clock starts ticking down people are
saying don't do it but we are part of
the team dog and we bring a different
aspect and kind of I think I feel like
attitude that some of the players
obviously haven't had before
so we go over there's 15 seconds left we
go to get a gatorade jug we go over
and there's a guy right when we walk up
to it he goes no
no
no
and we thought we don't have a chance
bro this is that freaking you know that
liquid that little liquid Warden this
dude's shutting us down bruh you know
this dude's at little uh that little
beverage Al Qaeda or whatever family he
goes no
if you're gonna Gatorade a coach
use water
and so he points at the water jug dude
so now we got the water jug bro we're
not even on this team
but we're not even on the scene I went
to LSU
if I'm real honest dude I mean but I
will say man that I if I never felt more
part of a team bro at this point ever in
my life since I played in a city
Championship man when I was in 11 and 12
on the Covington day Hawks
anyway dude so we we start looking for
the coach and I guess like we had some
we just went the wrong way and then
there he is man and you could tell he's
excited right could feel the energy
coming off him people are cheering we're
cheering
and uh yeah
we just baptized him baby and um
and it was just then we're dancing with
the team man it was
I feel like
I mean I feel like a member of the team
man you know and I feel like
I just there's no way I could never not
cheer for that program now
you know especially after all we did
against Florida
and I mean I don't know I I somebody
said have two people that aren't on a
team ever Gatorade shower the coach dude
I don't know bro
but um but it was a dream come true man
and we got the win
and and Caleb had been going there since
he was a baby he showed me a picture on
the phone he was a baby there and his
parents had and they're right by a hot
dog
and you could see he was just a little
bit bigger than that Frank
and so he'd been there since he was you
know
he was you know he was something in the
orange baby back then and look and look
I love SEC football there's nothing
better than SEC football you can pretend
with these other teams you know Mountain
you know Johnson or whatever that team
is or whatever UCLA all this [ __ ] that's
trash bro that's trash dude knock knock
who's there
SEC football dude where it's at
so and I'd give anything for this team I
would have donated blood right there on
the sidelines
if somebody would have split open I
would have damn donated blood or if
somebody would have got bit by a snake I
would have sucked it I would have sucked
the damn venom out of them you know I
mean just I mean it just it was just an
amazing place to see a football
and you will love it if you get a chance
and
um but yeah I'm a there's no way I could
not be a Tennessee Vols fan now it'd be
absolutely impossible man I'm still been
texting with some of the players man and
just you know I'm training now so I hope
to see you guys on the field baby go
Vols